and that actually amazing I wanted to
ask you when is the last time you felt
powerless we had our first fatality of
the year and gun gun violence fatality a
young man Adrian is his name I think he
was I think it was 16 and when I can I
go to the vigils that we have you know
the good news is we had nine oh it's not
good news that's the thing I mean the
good news is that nine homicides last
year is dramatically down from when I
was a kid we had more than 20 in a city
our size but every one of those
obviously feels like a failure and we've
done so much on gun violence we
implemented this this group violence
intervention strategy that I think is
the the best thinking at a john jay
college and the national network for
safe communities and we've got law
enforcement in the faith community in
the social sector working together and
I'm proud of it and we we do good things
and I think we've saved lives but
nothing makes you more powerless than
when you're there with the family of
someone who lost their child to gun
violence and you're supposed to be in
charge the mayor people and I think
there's also a feeling an informal
feeling of because we project especially
you know the law enforcement side of
government projects a kind of
omnipotence or omniscience to where it
almost feels like if somebody died it's
because we let them and so I never feel
more powerless at least as a mayor then
when I'm in a situation like that
dealing with gun violence where we just
you know and I'm we're fighting it with
one hide-and tied behind our back
because the state won't let us do a lot
of things I think would be common
sensical and you just feel about that
big on a lighter note I often feel
powerless when Chaston and I are
negotiating over household chores
[Laughter]